did you have sex with your brother oh
god
i possibly but i did have sex with my
step-brother
um he has since passed away he
killed himself
r.i.p he was a very sweet boy
i had sex with a boy who i was told
after i had sex with him that he could
potentially be my brother
he does look like me we're never going
to do the dna test because i don't think
i'd be able to handle that
um but there are whispers in the family
because our families are very close whoa
and we sort of grew up together so a lot
of filipinos are related though yeah
back to the original point thank you
that you said was very successful so i
don't want to know
and this is like you met as adults or
this was during like a child we grew up
together my his grand his dad
my dad and his grandpa were best friends
in the philippines i don't know what
they were doing in the 70s if they were
swapping partners but somehow i have a
family friend who looks exactly like me
and i had sex with him when i was 19
for a whole year and then only later to
find out through his grandma
she was like wait like
you know there could be a chance
all the while everyone's like you guys
looking like each other
and we're like yeah that's what happens
when people date they end up looking
like each other but we really do look
like each other
i really want to see and
worst of all is that like
there was something about him you know i
found him attractive you know they say
like you are like repulsed by your own
it was not a pheromone match i remember
feeling like i didn't like the way he
smelled i didn't like the way a lot of
things about him but is that like a
third world thing though i don't know
wait pheromones are a third one no the
way he smelled like was there like uh he
was born and raised
that's racist
everyone from the philippines stinks
he's [ __ ] us
to say that i don't know exactly how
you're being raised indoor plumbing it
depends
a metropolis yeah manila is one of the
biggest cities in the western world
andrew that's a good point smelled a
girl's breath and either been super
attracted to it or super unattracted to
it yeah
that's like what we're kind of yeah but
that's mostly if if they've uh cleaned
their mouth
or or
it's just not your biological match
i don't know if that's breath yeah i
think that's a little bit more like the
body odor i think so do you like some
women's body odor and some you don't i
don't want to say like but like it's
more tolerable it's like uh see i've got
guys who literally will put their nose
and just
take the biggest whiff because they're
it's a pheromone match
yeah i get that
you want to go no not on youtube
i'm sure it's flowers or daisies or
whatever do you do have you spoken to
him since
um
yeah
okay another question i've always wanted
this was it like a like a
lego oh there's that there's husband
dick and then there's brother big
brother brother jake might be is it like
exactly the amount like did you guys
lock in and go oh [ __ ] like yeah like
yeah
honestly he did kind of [ __ ] like me
he did [ __ ] you like you yeah a little
bit in what way and i didn't like it
it just like there was a clashing of
energies there it's like it wasn't
because it wasn't a biological match i
remember like
yeah getting the feminine the jingies
after did he also get on all fours after
until he died
[Applause]
you